[Music]
one of the biggest shows on television
these days is AMC's The Walking Dead is
massive this Sunday's season premiere
got bigger ratings among adults than any
entertainment series this fall that is
HUGE
yeah well I was just told a few minutes
ago that a big fan of The Walking Dead
is here tonight we've asked him to come
out and briefly explain the popularity
of the show I haven't met him yet I'm
told he's here right now please welcome
Hamilton Davis let's get him in here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Hamilton you you look like a zombie I am
a zombie
although the politically correct term is
decaying American let me get this
straight
zombies watch The Walking Dead duh of
course we're big fans the show presents
us as the complex creatures we are
crafty resourceful with an insatiable
zest for life what do you talk about
your relentless killing machines bent on
destroying humanity point taken
but we also enjoy fine wine art gallery
openings and the novels of Joyce Carol
Oates okay none of that is portrayed in
the show it's strongly implied okay if
you're so sophisticated why do you wear
those filthy old zombie clothes hello
this is shabby chic this suits made a
pre-distressed Portuguese linen and it
cost more than your car all right you
know what you're being really rude I
mean I invited you on my television show
you call this a television show looks
more like an elementary school
production of crap you know what you're
being awfully obnoxious for a guy who
shuffles around eating brains
I'd love to eat some brains but at this
show they're clearly in short supply
you know I've had it with this jerk hey
Einstein you have to shoot a zombie in
the head
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I have the feeling he's still alive yeah
so I
are you sitting up well I'm not doing
very well